[Applaudissements]
j'ai un petit explorateur dans mon
ventre
normalement il devrait sortir d'ici un
mois enfin j'espère
quand il sera sorti cette explorateur il
aimerait bien explorer tout le monde
comme son papa
mais il aura des parents différents des
autres parents des autres enfants pardon
il aura deux particularités dès sa
naissance sa maman est très spéciale
et son papa allait encore plus
et j'ai un petit secret à vous dire mais
je l'ai pas au courant il vient de Metz
on passe la parole au bébé
on l'appelle bébé chou
pour moi ce sont les meilleurs parents
du monde
mon père quand il rentre le soir il me
raconte les histoires qu'il a passées
cette journée et moi évidemment bien sûr
j'adore les histoires qui me racontent
et quand je
sens qu'il me raconte l'histoire je tape
sur mon le ventre de la maman Elise pour
les qui sentent que je
que je suis ici
ma maman quand elle se lève elle va
prendre sa douche comme tous les matins
elle m'emmène avec elle normal
elle va dans la douche elle chante elle
danse bon elle chante mal parce que
c'est mon père qui dit qui le dit lui
dit
et j'aime bien j'aime beaucoup ça
mais en fait ils ont mille et un
problème
et même moi j'en ai mille et un problème
par exemple comment ils vont faire pour
me porter
me doucher me mettre
à table le faire faire du vélo plus tard
donc oui j'aurais des problèmes et ils
ont non
ils en auront aussi
mais je les adore déjà
on va parler de ta maman je vais parler
de ta maman maman
Elise elle a 33 ans elle porte mon bébé
elle a vécu un drame
dans sa vie en 2017 un jour de 2017 lors
de son entraînement au marathon de Paris
elle était alors une nette brillante
étudiante en eux-mêmes neuvième année de
médecine
six mois après je l'ai rencontré
je l'ai rencontré par un groupe facebook
AVC jeunes sur Suivant où on n'était pas
mal de d'AVC
et on se rencontrer
et je l'ai rencontré
c'était un cauchemar pour elle
être paralysé
de toute ce côté gauche moi j'avais eu
une parasite de mon compte droit et
j'avais la phase qui me
m'interrompait dans ma diction mais elle
elle avait un AVC du côté gauche
et
quand je lui ai dit que
que je l'aimais
je lui ai dit ça
on peut pas applaudir
[Musique]
c'était un cauchemar pour elle mais elle
a terminé ses études de médecine
brillamment et j'étais fier d'elle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand j'ai rencontré Louis
il avait donc déjà eu son accident
c'était un brillant étudiant en droit
européen il était bilingue
il était travaillé au moins au Parlement
à Bruxelles tu es presque trilingue ce
qui parlait français anglais et polonais
un petit peu polonais
et il a vécu le même drame que moi
mais en plus de perdre toute la
motricité de son côté droit comme il
vous l'a dit il est devenu aphasique
complet qu'est-ce que c'est l'aphasie
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut plus parler du
tout il avait les mots dans sa tête mais
impossible de construire des phrases
alors pour me draguer c'était un peu
compliqué
j'ai réussi il a réussi heureusement
qu'il est beau
mais comme moi il a il a tout
reconstruit de 2-0
il avait 24 ans
il est aussi comme moi passé par une
phase en fauteuil roulant qui a duré un
peu près un mois
et imaginez-vous juste 30 secondes en
fauteuil roulant avec une seule main
valide
on tourne en rond du coup ça nous a
motivé pour remarcher
Louis son combat quotidien c'était de
réapprendre à parler ces choses faites
maintenant qu'il est devant vous et
trouver un métier parce qu'il avait fini
ses études
c'est maintenant chose faite mais ça son
combat a duré plusieurs années j'ai
assisté à sa reconstruction qui fut
lente mais fulgurante dès qu'il s'est vu
pousser des ailes après notre rencontre
tu as raison mon bébé chou on est
spéciaux moi je serai toujours ton papa
et maman elle va être toujours ta maman
mais on va essayer de faire les choses
quotidiennement
mon père durant ma rééducation il m'a
dit une chose très importante c'est
l'avenir appartient aux audacieux
donc c'est une phrase qu'il faut retenir
mais on va devoir être des parents
audacieux ce n'est pas de la tarte
donc deux parents ça c'est validé
mais qui ont deux bras valides
c'est pas validé non plus
mais on sort sortira toujours on s'en
est toujours sorti
en faisant des projets à deux pourquoi
pas à trois
l'amour nous a déjà fait réaliser
beaucoup de projets que beaucoup
pensaient impossible en 2019 Louis il
avait pas encore de travail il s'est
attelé pendant un an à organiser un tour
de France et d'Europe en Berlingo
aménagé en passant des centaines voire
des milliers de coups de fil pour créer
son réseau et organiser nos conférences
j'ai toujours pas comment il a fait moi
je terminais ma thèse de médecine et je
finissais mon internat donc il a tout
gérer tout seul
chapeau
lors de ce
lors de ce tour en août et septembre
2019 moi aussi j'ai lancé un défi à
Louis comme vous la comme il vous l'a
dit j'étais je me préparais au marathon
de Paris en 2017 lors de mon accident et
je voulais absolument recourir c'était
mon but ultime
alors je lui ai dit un jour dans les
Pyrénées dans un camping bon Louis moi
je veux recourir on va faire 1 km par
jour pendant tout le tour là j'avais
peur de sa réaction mais en fait le soir
même on a enfilé nos baskets et on s'est
mis à courir bon on avait omis que on
était dans les Pyrénées ça montait un
petit peu trop il fait 305 degrés mais
on a fait de nous un kilomètre bon en un
quart d'heure un quart d'heure j'étais
rouge écarlate mais on l'a fait on était
trop content
mais on s'est pas arrêté là on a fait
nos 1 km à Madrid en Espagne très chaud
aussi et arrivé à Lisbonne je me
souviens encore de sa petite tête avec
son sourire au bout d'un kilomètre il me
fait et Elise viens on essaye de cette
fois
donc du coup moi j'adore aussi les défis
on a fait deux
pardon on a fait 2 km et là vous vous
voyez nos sourires après nos deux
kilomètres je crois que je me
souviendrai toujours deux jours là je me
suis ok on a fait un on a fait deux on
pourra faire
on pourra recourir peut-être par
marathon mais on pourra recourir et
prendre du plaisir j'étais trop contente
ensuite après ce tour là j'ai dû finir
mon clinica en région parisienne et nous
avons décidé de déménager en
Haute-Savoie pour y faire notre vie
arrivé en Haute-Savoie cette fois Louis
avait son travail à temps plein il a
passé un concours pour être dans
l'institut régional d'administration de
Metz il a raté le premier concours
c'était un oral alors un oral pour un
aphasique je croyais pas du tout qu'il
allait la voir mais
il a raté la première fois il m'a dit
non mais je vais le repasser je me suis
tu es sûr c'est une bonne idée mais bon
rien n'arrête oui du coup il a repassé
en juin 2019 il a été pris il m'a
vraiment scotché vous pouvez applaudir
[Musique]
et du coup arrivé en Haute-Savoie
monsieur s'est inscrit à la piscine
et il a rencontré plein de gens il a
surtout rencontré une association
d'Handisport et il y a il leur a parlé
son nouveau projet parce que un tour
d'Europe ça suffisait pas il voulait
faire maintenant un tour du lac Léman
entre ici
avec des conférences parce que tricycle
tout seul c'est trop facile du coup
pendant notre tour du lac Léman on a
fait environ 20 30 km par jour et une
conférence un jour sur deux
c'était un moment vraiment inoubliable
après ce tour là Louis m'a dit mais moi
je veux continuer les conférences bon
moi j'étais claquée de fatigue j'ai dit
ok les conférences mais vas-y tu y vas
tout seul cette fois donc il sait pas
c'est pas freiner il a dit ok bah moi je
vais m'inscrire au théâtre
mais théâtre pas n'importe quel théâtre
le théâtre d'improvisation pour un
aphasique quand il m'a dit ça j'ai dit
mais tu es sûr bon je connais maintenant
je le connais je
tout est possible avec lui donc il s'est
inscrit au théâtre il m'a dit oui moi
j'aimerais bien monter mon spectacle
humoristique sur la phase
donc c'est pas un seul en scène il
appelle ça
il a déjà plus de 6 conférences à son
actif donc une qui a été filmée dans un
vrai théâtre à Lyon
chapeau
et pour financer ses conférences
maintenant il a monté son
auto-entreprise qui s'appelle s'adapter
Consulting
on a deux travaux
qui nous plaisent et on a
c'est battu on s'est battu et on a eu
surtout de la patience 8 ans de patience
pour arriver à ça aujourd'hui on est ici
devant vous
à une conférence TEDx
et maintenant on est à 3 devant vous
avec des bijoux
mais
en 2022
on a couru les deux de 10 km du marathon
d'Annecy en 2023 j'ai recouru les 10 km
d'Annecy
mais en hommage à Babychou et maman chou
qui ne pouvaient pas courir mais
j'espère bien qu'ils pourront un jour
l'année prochaine courir avec moi
maman chou et bébé chou mais on a des
autres projets sportifs nous inquiétez
pas ne vous inquiétez pas on a un projet
assez gros conséquent c'est un tour
du Mont Blanc donc
arrêtez de rigoler mais on a un projet
du Tour du Mont-Blanc on a un projet
de traverser du lac d'Annecy
un triathlon XS
etc etc mais on a aussi des projets
littéraires Élise est en train d'écrire
enfin non non elle a écrit un témoignage
de sa rééducation qu'elle va bientôt
publier en 2024 et on a un deuxième
projet
en 2025
qu'on a préparé
nos projets à trois à court terme seront
que des filles adaptation quotidienne on
a bien conscience
on va galérer pour le mettre sur sa
chaise haute l'enlever de sa chaise
haute le mettre sur son siège auto
l'enlever de son siège auto le nourrir
le promener en poussette tout ça à une
seule main on sait très bien que ça va
être galère
mais je pense que maintenant on est prêt
on a une capacité d'adaptation qui est
hors norme
je pense que on peut s'adapter à toute
situation je pense que tout le monde
dans la salle a vécu des expériences une
des épreuves difficiles dans sa vie mais
faut toujours transformer ses épreuves
en force on a tous cette capacité là et
c'est ressources là on n'est pas
exceptionnel avec lui
peut-être que la vie est dure et
[Musique]
pas bien fait mais on est capable de
réaliser des projets A3 coûte que coûte
avec Louis souvenez-vous que la vie est
toujours fragile et instable avec Louis
on a on aurait pu mourir à 24 ans pour
lui 27 ans pour moi grâce à notre
famille et nos amis on a réussi à s'en
sortir ça a pris beaucoup de temps
mais on peut s'en sortir toujours
lundi parentalité est un défi je pense
que c'est le plus gros défi de notre vie
en même temps être parent c'est le défi
de beaucoup de monde on sait qu'on va y
arriver
avec Louis vous aviez qu'on a mis les un
projet en plus on vous a pas tout
raconté si on n'aura pas le temps
mais on est toujours obligé de se
freiner dans nos projets mais il y en a
toujours un ou deux qui qui arrive à
motiver l'autre en trois secondes
d'ailleurs venir ici à huit mois et demi
de grossesse presque 9 c'était un peu
fou
mais on a fait ça prudemment
rassurez-vous je ne vais pas accoucher
sur cette fin j'espère
non ça va c'est bon
et maintenant vous connaissez bien Louis
alias papa chou
vous connaissez bien Elise alias maman
chou et vous connaissez bien bébé chou
qui veut s'appeler
ce le prénom qu'on a choisi le jour de
sa naissance
et est-ce qu'on a
est-ce que vous pouvez peu vous poser
une question
vous quels sont vos projets
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]